that's pretty good for your first time
oh I think we should fare very well I'm
very well versed in rifles shotguns
pistols sniper rifles all type of
weaponry never shot a gun before and
kind of scared these arms weren't made
for gun shooting these arms were made
through you know I come from Kansas City
Missouri and mostly all my family's all
farmers so I'm kind of used to shooting
a shotgun or different guns as a kid I'm
looking forward to the gun range portion
of this competition I think it's going
to be a great chance at retribution take
a breath exhale to to the top one to the
head and then put it back down I mean I
would feel pretty good you never done it
you're doing it under a rapid we set up
two targets at 25 meters and we did to
the face to the face to the face
switching between the target two rounds
in this target mm elect argot and in two
rounds in the right target Oh in the
face and the same in the face in the
face
Chevy over the face go
go probably a little faster we've been
better but the shots are really good
these guys did an outstanding job a lot
better than I anticipated they would
JD's never shot in his life so he did
really well considering that was his
first time the difference is between us
playing a game against you guys and how
much of a difference there was between
skill levels on that and paired - this
was not nearly as great I was just
thinking don't crowd on I was I wasn't
thinking though
there wasn't really much to mess up it
was more just like I was thinking just
take your time and don't be hasty don't
try to look cool or something for the
cameras because I was like I don't have
time to mess up and hit the ceiling how
much trapping over this or something I
don't know